[MUSIC]
Please be seated.
Graduates, honored guests,
faculty, staff, families, and friends.
Welcome to the 2015 graduation ceremony at
Stanford University's Graduate School
of Business.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Graduates, as you know,
studying at the GSB means so
much more than mastering the concepts
of management, it is much more
about personal transformation.
As you sit before us,
eager to receive your diplomas,
I encourage you to think about
how you have changed and
grown during your time at the GSB.
Your graduation today celebrates
all you have done and
become, and
your readiness to have a dramatic and
positive impact on the organizations
you will lead, manage,
or found, and through those organizations,
the communities they serve.
What you have accomplished at the GSB,
you have not accomplished alone.
You have learned and received help,
guidance, mentorship and
support from many quarters,
all of which are represented here today.
First, you're sitting shoulder
to shoulder with your classmates
as you have throughout your time here.
Think how much you have learned from one
another in squads, clubs, study trips,
talk, touchy-feely, or
just in quiet conversation together.
You have forged bonds here that
will become lifelong friendships,
which will nurture and
sustain you in the years ahead.
Take a moment to show your
appreciation for one another.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sitting behind me on the stage is
a group of faculty who represent the more
than 200 tenure-line faculty and
practitioners, who have been
your teachers, coaches, mentors,
study trip companions,
career advisors, and so much more.
I would ask the faculty to stand so
that your students can
express their appreciation.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And at various locations throughout
the amphitheater A star from the MBA,
MSX, and PhD programs.
Without their tireless efforts
on behalf of all of us,
none of us would be
here celebrating today.
I ask the staff to stand if
they are not already standing,
wherever they are, and be recognized.
[APPLAUSE]
I have left the most
important for last.
Each of you has been
supported by families and
friends, as you will be
throughout your lives.
They have provided encouragement,
validation, Love, and
yes, in many cases,
financial support, too.
While we will hand the diplomas to you,
you know that in
parentheses after your name belong the
names of those who have nurtured you and
supported you along the way.
This is your opportunity to stand And
say thank you to your friends and
family who are celebrating your
mutual accomplishment with you.
[APPLAUSE]
These days it is
difficult to venture
into the world
of social media
without encountering
an article or
discussion about
whether Silicon Valley Is
in the midst of
another bubble.
Whatever your opinion on that matter,
it is hard to dispute that the GSB
is itself in a bit of a bubble.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a different kind of bubble,
of course.
It's a bubble in which you have
the space to learn and to explore.
To discover incredible
classmates in distant countries.
To dream about the future and
imagine your place within it.
And not just to explore without,
but also within,
on a journey of self-discovery.
So it is a good bubble,
but a bubble nonetheless.
Today, alas, as you walk across
the stage to receive your diplomas,
you leave the bubble and
enter what during your time at the GSB,
you have referred to as the real world.
As I hand you your diploma and shake
your hand, en route to the real world,
This is what I will be hoping for
you in the years ahead.
First that you will take with
you the aspirational part of you
that we have tried to nurture
during your time at the GSB.
The cornerstone of the GSB reads,
dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet, And to the people
who are about to dream them up.
You are those people.
Dream big and hold on to those dreams.
Change lives, organisations and the world.
Second, that you will live your own life.
You only have one, and
it is yours to live.
You will encounter many people who will
have opinions about what is right for you.
About the path you should follow.
You'll be tempted by opportunities that
will look good rather than be good.
Ask yourself, what you really want,
and have the courage to pursue it.
Third, and this may seem odd coming
from a business school dean, but
I hope you will keep your
career in perspective.
There were many great viewpoints
in this year's view from the top.
But I have to say, I agree in particular
with a point that Mitt Romney made.
In the end we don't have that much
control over the world around us, and
how it impacts our lives.
The vagaries of the global economy and
politics will buffet you.
But your true friends and
family will always be there for you, and
that is what will make the difference.
Always remember what is really important.
Finally, I hope that you will stay
connected to and support one another.
I have the privilege of meeting numerous
alumni across many graduating classes
all over the world.
I am always so pleased that they
remain bonded over time, and
that they're always there for one another.
Look to each other for confidence,
courage and strength, and
stay connected to us as well.
Our graduation speaker today is
an alumnus whose passion for business,
social change, and family,
make him a quintessential GSBer.
Tom Stayer graduated from
the Stanford GSB with an MBA in 1983.
Tom was an Arjay Miller Scholar,
and I am so pleased that at age 99,
Arjay is with us today to recognize
this year's Arjay Miller Scholars.
Please join me in welcoming Arjay.
[APPLAUSE]
Back to
Tom Steyer.
Tom went on to Goldman Sachs,
where he worked in the risk arbitrage
department under Robert Rubin.
In January 1986,
he founded Farallon Capital Management,
a pioneer in the practice of
absolute return investing,
a strategy that aims to produce
a positive absolute return,
regardless of the directions
of financial markets.
In 2010, Tom announced that
he was turning his attention
to having a broader social impact.
He is actively engaged in climate politics
through his next gen climate political
organization, and
works to promote economic development and
environmental protection in California and
across the country.
Tom is a former member of
the GSB's advisory council.
And a current member of
the Stanford Board of Trustees.
Together with his wife, Kat Taylor, who's
a Stanford JD MBA from the Class of 86,
he was instrumental in the creation
of the joint business and
law school, Steyer-Taylor Center for
Energy Policy and Finance, which
examines issues of funding and public
policy surrounding alternative energy.
Tom and
Kat also funded the TomKat Center for
Sustainable Energy at
Stanford's Precourt Institute,
which provides research grants for
alternative energy innovations in wind,
solar and
advanced transmission technologies.
Tom and Kat joined Warren Buffett,
Bill and Melinda Gates, and
others in the giving pledge, a promise
to donate the majority of their wealth.
To charitable and non-profit
activities during their lifetimes.
They created and funded the Oakland-based
Beneficial State Bank and Foundation,
which provides loans and banking services,
to under served small businesses,
communities and individuals in California,
and along the west coast.
It is a pleasure to have Tom with us.
Please join me in giving a warm
GSB welcome to Tom Stire.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Wow.
[APPLAUSE] Well,
that was a very nice introduction, Garth.
I wanna thank you all for having me here.
And I know that you're all ready to get
out of here and celebrate with your
families, because 32 years ago, I was
sitting exactly where you're sitting,
and I know that a commencement speaker
gets one line if he or she is lucky.
The best line from a commencement
speaker that I remember,
dealt with what to remember
as you leave the house.
Keys, wallet, phone.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's good advice,
I use it every single day,
I used it this morning.
But it only gets you out the door.
And I'm hoping to talk today about what
happens after you leave the house.
I'm not gonna give you my one line yet but
I'm determined to come up with one line
that you guys can remember in 32 years.
We'll see if it's as good as key,
wallet, phone.
And let me say this, when I was
sitting where you're sitting now,
I was excited to restart my career, but
I was very sorry to leave my friends,
my woodside house, my unheated pool,
my girlfriend who is now my wife,
and old Lahanda Road- to go live
in the office at Goldman Sachs.
It was a very mixed bag.
But let me say this.
American business has real
structural advantages.
As graduates of the GSB, you have
both the capability and the capacity
to lead the world at scale and
those advantages are only gonna grow.
In GSP terms, they are sustainable and
they are defensible.
And as a society, we may be facing
enormous challenges, but while government
gets to set the rules, it’s business
that can really push the envelope.
And here’s why,
here’s what I think are unique and
sustainable advantages that are in 2015.
One, an awareness and dedication to
the power of information technology.
And two, the ability to have a flexible
culture and incentive system.
So let me just talk about just
those two points for a second.
Information technology.
A very smart investor said to me about
six months ago, that in his opinion,
in every single business in the world,
the competitor that was the most IT
enabled was the competitor that was gonna
come out on top over the next ten years.
And that's every business.
He was talking about farming, for
instance, that the farmers with
the best IT were gonna win.
The private sector is free to invest
in the information technology it needs.
It's a huge advantage and it becomes,
itself, the cutting edge.
My wife, who as Garth pointed out,
and I'm a humble MBA.
My wife is a snotty JD MBA.
>> [LAUGH]
>> She and I started a community bank,
and it has about over $500 million
worth of assets, but we've tried
to develop proprietary credit scoring IT
>> To compete
to get the lowest default rates and
provide the best pricing and service.
With the right technology,
we think we can outperform banks with over
two trillion dollars worth of assets.
In 2010, President Obama said,
Washington lags a generation
behind in how we do business.
With all due respect for
the President of the United States,
I don’t think it’s one generation.
Think about healthcare.gov.
The Patent Office receives over 80%
of its applications electronically.
It then prints them out, scans them, and
enters them by hand Into
a case management system.
Average processing time, three years.
Every federal agency is depending
on Congress for funding, and
Congress is not looking
to increase tech funding.
They're not even looking to
support necessary upgrades.
So where as government is large and
unwieldy, you can be nimble, innovative,
and creative.
This university,
this valley are testimonies to
the really power of creative IT.
Culture, the second point,
what you do to define your mission
and how that mission informs every hiring
decision, every compensation decision,
and every strategic decision means you
can not only get the best people, but
you can organize them effectively.
The private sector has a unique
ability to set agreed upon goals and
work seamlessly to achieve them.
By having a mission and setting your
incentives based on achieving that
mission, you have an opportunity
to create an incredible impact.
A very cynical friend of mine
told me 35 years ago, and
I think this is really only
a part of what I'm talking about.
But his statement was,
people do what you pay them to do.
I watched the impact of different
incentive schemes at Farallon Management,
which was the investment management
firm that I founded, over the years.
And the impact was far
beyond what I imagined, so
I know how powerful personnel
compensation can be.
But Stanford's mission is about more
than gaining the highest gap return.
Garth talked about the motto.
Change lives, change organizations,
change the world.
Sounds like unlimited upsides.
What could go wrong?
So, the question of the day is- how do
smart people, with all the advantages,
make dumb decisions?
It's not by being wrong.
Because we're talking about smart
people who do good analysis.
The way smart people make big mistakes
is by using the wrong framework.
It's by looking too narrowly at a problem.
You can be too limited either in
terms of time or in terms of scope,
in general if you wanna solve
a thorny problem, make it bigger.
Take information from outside any
one circumscribed discipline.
So this is my one line of the day,
the one thing I want you to remember.
It's two words.
Be open.
Widen the aperture on your camera.
Use your peripheral vision.
Be open to different
sources of information.
It can be stressful to do
that in the short term,
it can seem like a waste of time.
But using a wide lens spurs creativity and
collaboration, it makes you more flexible
and it respects all stakeholders.
Let's take a quick look at
just two examples of what
I think is the challenge of our
generation, carbon pollution.
For decades, the Chinese government
focused exclusively on the GDP growth
numbers in making their energy decisions.
If you’re just running
the traditional accounting numbers,
coal makes the most sense.
It’s cheap on those numbers.
And if you're trying to raise hundreds
of millions of people out of poverty and
into the middle class,
why wouldn't you wanna use the cheapest
source of energy to grow your GDP?
That was the single bottom line for
the Chinese government for decades, but
their GDP calculations didn't include any
cost for health and environmental impacts.
And just because it doesn't
appear on your spreadsheet
doesn't mean it doesn't
exist in the real world.
Coal still accounts for more than 80% of
China's energy generation, and breathing
the air in Beijing is the equivalent of
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day.
Not recognizing and quantifying costs
does not mean those costs don't matter,
they just don't matter
in your decision making.
China has changed, now it computes and
observes two bottom lines,
GDP growth and pollution.
As a friend of mine says, if you don't
measure it, you can't manage it.
So let's look for
an example of openness, and lo and
behold it's the Stanford energy project.
Stanford had to redo its heat and
electricity systems over the past
two years, led by the real estate
department under Bob Reidy.
How mundane, you say.
Not really mundane.
Before the decision was finalized, the
real estate department met with a group of
graduate students, including my son,
who worried that Stanford wasn't
taking a broad enough view of what
they were trying to accomplish.
And after the meeting, I asked my
son how it went and he said, well,
we didn’t change their minds in any way,
but they certainly changed mine.
They knew way more about
the energy system than we did, and
they were incorporating every concern
we had into their decision making.
And I asked Bob what he thought of
the meeting, and he said, wow, they asked
great questions, they love Stanford,
they care about the same things we do.
Being open really went both ways.
Bob did a great job of
opening up his aperture and
thinking about what he was trying
to accomplish in a broad sense.
And as a result, Stanford is gonna save
a lot of energy and a lot of water.
We're gonna have 65% renewables by 2016,
and we're gonna save a lot
of money along the way.
More than any other school,
Stanford University has the concept
of openness in its DNA.
We’re blessed with the weather and
a campus that makes collaboration and
collegiality easy.
We spring from a West Coast culture
of friendliness and cooperation, and
the university has deliberately sought to
foster cross-disciplinary problem solving.
The GSB is thought to be the best
business school in the world,
so you're starting from a place
of immense possibility.
You're leaving with all
the tools to make a lasting,
tremendous difference on this world,
but it cannot be all about you.
You are the heirs to
an extraordinary system and
the extraordinary competitive advantage
I was describing, just as I was.
I think we all should be
really grateful for that.
We should use the advantages
that American society and
American business gives us,
because people have sacrificed for
hundreds of years to pave
the road we stand on today.
I hope you succeed magnificently, and
I hope you share your success
with the rest of the world.
Frankly, I'm expecting some millionaires,
and some billionaires, and
some very talented very hardworking people
of modest means, to come out of this class
and that's all great, that can't be
the measure of your accomplishment though.
Take a wide view when
solving your problems, and
an even bigger view when
defining your success.
That will make everything you do fun and
constructive.
I love my business career and
now I'm loving my next career.
My two words, be open to the whole world,
please, and God bless you.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It is now my great honor and
pleasure to introduce you to
the GSB PhD class of 2015.
Our PhD program is small and exclusive,
with an admissions rate of under 7%.
These individuals come here as
students dedicating themselves to
years of course work and
an intensive apprenticeship in conducting
research in their chosen fields.
As a sign, consider that the students
who are graduating today
began their careers in
the old South Building.
Having become true experts,
they leave us as colleagues,
setting out on a path to
create new knowledge.
Today, we formally celebrate
their transition from students
to future intellectual leaders, who will
play an important role in shaping our
understanding of business and management.
After their advisors place the hood of
the Stanford Business School on them,
they will join us on stage as we welcome
them into our profession as colleagues.
Dianne Le, Executive Director of the PHD
Program, will now read their names and
their dissertation advisor will hood them.
>> Urjay Ng.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Peter Valmy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Oystein Daljord.
>> Emily Garbinski.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[LAUGH]
>> Vivian Groves.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tamar Admati Kreps.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Larson.
>> Bella Rosencrantz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Dergesh Saraf.
>> Sue Xia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Pavel Zrimoff.
>> The Master of Arts and
Business Research recognizes the
accomplishments of students have completed
the coursework and fulfilled the research
requirements of the Masters degree,
and thus have became domain experts,
but who are not continuing on to do
further work required for the PhD degree.
Although none of this year's
candidates for the Master of Arts and
Business Research are present for today's
ceremony, their names are listed in
the program and we celebrate their
accomplishments nonetheless.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> This year marks the 43rd class of
students who graduate with Certificate in
Public Management and Social Innovation.
Founded by Dean Emeritus, Arjay Miller,
the certificate program educates leaders
for social and environmental change.
Today's graduates really do embody
the spirit of our motto, change lives,
change organizations, change the world.
These students have already
shown their commitment,
using management skills to
alleviate global social problems.
For example, they participated in a wide
range of social innovation courses,
covering topics such as healthcare
innovation, education reform,
business at the bottom of the pyramid,
and sustainable energy markets.
They explored roles with
high social impact,
such as board governance,
impact investing, and philanthropy.
They traveled on social innovation trips
to places like Bangladesh, Bhutan,
Brazil, China, Kenya and
Rwanda, to see for
themselves what is possible to
address issues of extreme poverty,
access to healthcare, education,
sustainability and more.
And finally, some of them have developed
their own social enterprise and
are ready to launch
right after graduation.
I am proud to tell you that this year we
have 118 recipients of the Certificate in
Public Management and Social Innovation.
Their names are listed in
the commencement program.
I now ask those 118 students to stand and
be recognized for
completing a formal course of
study in the management of public,
nonprofit, social issue organizations.
Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Good afternoon,
on this festive and beautiful day.
It is my pleasure as Director of
the Stanford MSX program, to present
this years graduates, who will receive the
degree of Master of Science in Management.
The mission of the MSX program is to
provide experienced leaders, men and
women, who have spent at least
eight years in professional and
management roles,
the opportunity to prepare themselves for
increasingly senior positions
in organizations they will lead.
The program is a full-time,
year-long course of academic study, giving
these students an all too rare chance for
reflection and growth in the midst
of an already accomplished career.
Simultaneously, they bring to the GSB
a perspective shaped by experience with
difficult organizational challenges,
enriching our academic
community as a result.
While studying at Stanford, these students
carry the title of Sloan Fellows,
a tradition that dates to the year
the program was founded in 1957.
This year's Fellows came to Stanford
from across the United States and
22 additional countries.
Many Fellows are sponsored
by their employers.
Others will be joining, or
creating innovative new
enterprises after graduation.
Having completed all the academic
requirements of the program, this year's
89 Sloan Fellows will join the worldwide
family of Stanford Business School alumni.
On behalf of the administration
of the program,
and the faculty who have taught them,
join me in wishing
each of them great fulfillment and success
in the next phase of their careers.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I will now read their names while
Dean Saloner presents the diplomas.
Romy Abu Armillah.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Commander Steven Cesar Acosta.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Asheesh Malhun Agrawal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Vinaki Eich.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Steven Elberon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
Mark Allen.
Chi Wi Ung.
[APPLAUSE]
Minoru Aoki.
Clement Armstrong.
[APPLAUSE],
Martin Ati.
Jarrett Keith Benevidez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Bearman.
>> Roberto Blanco.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Rudolph Wolfgang Broom.
[APPLAUSE],
Ken Sai.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
Marco Kimaji.
[APPLAUSE]
Suraj Chatrath.
Jason Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Corin Crawford.
[APPLAUSE],
Timothy Haman Cronin.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
Richard Jin Coomdai.
[APPLAUSE],
Travis J Demister.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
Bo Dong.
[APPLAUSE]
Sebastian Hechaverria.
>> Tomohiro Jajiri.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> James Ellison.
>> Karina Deanna Erthel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ralph Ewig.
Se Hao Go.
[APPLAUSE],
Nitton Goyal.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zane A.
Glommely.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicole Yen Hu.
Junichi Herosuka.
[APPLAUSE],
Jeff Holiday.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Jules Hough.
[APPLAUSE],
Charles Shay.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
Daniel Jiminez.
[APPLAUSE]
Ricardo Justo Jaccobucci.
Kamel Karr.
[APPLAUSE]
Kierel Kazanlee.
Damon Katut.
[APPLAUSE],
Daniel Kim.
Yu Kimura.
[APPLAUSE]
Jonathan Song Wong Ku.
Rui Goeeka.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
John Kun.
[APPLAUSE]
Monica Lease.
Cynthia Liao.
[APPLAUSE],
Tony Lewis.
Aaron Lu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jose Manu.
>> Phil Moritz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kyle Patrick McNeely.
>> Aaron Ming.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Robin Mojapatra.
>> Vino D'awson Morealeader.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Ricardo Netto.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Julie Oberweiss.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sergei Potsco.
>> Joshua Ramishur.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lowra Rudash.
>> Sarah Shawburt.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mark Jason Shmun.
>> Daniel Peter Scott.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Erico Sakiya.
>> Mike Seltzer
>> [APPLAUSE],
>> Bochney Shankar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shri Sharma.
>> Javier Andres Solana Rodriguez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Patrick Stapfor.
>> Amir Muhammad Raoul Sutan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Phillipe Sunjing.
>> Masahiro Suzuki.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zabo Jaba
>> Kenny Tan
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mata Thatai
>> Jerome Teo
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Diti Duku
>> Carolyn Ting
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Luca Toscani.
>> Kaylee VanDeHegh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eduardo Valla.
>> Andrew Wan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Danielle D Weiss
>> Kazuo Yamazaki
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Vu Serran.
>> Paulo Zagelo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Chung Charles Jiang.
>> All right, calm down.
You haven't graduated yet, okay?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Distinguished guests, faculty, staff,
families and friends.
>> The MBA students gathered
here before us today,
achieved great distinction 2 years ago
when they successfully navigated our
extremely competitive admissions process.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Since then,
they have acquired solid foundations
in general management.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> And have pursued deeper study
in their areas of interest.
They have engaged in personal growth and
built relationships that
will last a lifetime.
They have helped the school and the
community in many extremely valuable ways.
They are an impressive group,
and are ready and
worthy to join the ranks
of our illustrious alumni.
Therefore, ladies and gentlemen,
it's my great honor and
privilege to present to you
the Stanford MBA class of
2015.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You're the 90th MBA graduating class at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
and in my somewhat biased opinion,
the best one yet.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> As
you leave the lead lives of impact and
meaning, I fully expect back your
accomplishments at Stanford will pale in
comparison to your future achievements.
But I hope your memories of
the GSP will remain fresh, and
that you will stay
involved with the school.
All of them played an important role in
your academic experience ranging from
serving as judges in the executive
challenge acting as mentors
in entrepreneurial courses.
Our alumni also played a key role in
your graduation experience today.
Three years ago we had made the decision
to do graduation within the air
conditioned confines of Maples Pavilion,
but
the class of 2012 protested, came out
strongly in favor of having you all
have a sweltering graduation
experience here, okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's my wish that you will engage
with the GSB's academic mission
as alumni and give your time and
experience generously to future classes.
Your class has already demonstrated its
desire to stay connected to the GSB,
and to support the school
in a meaningful way
through your participation
in the class gift program.
I must recognize the extraordinary
result of 98.25% of you
pledging to give back to the GSB.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> For
the seven students who were not moved
by my half now, half later video,
we will hunt you down.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So,
at this time, I would like to ask the
members of the Student Association Senate
and the members of the seven
SA committees to please stand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Keep standing.
The SA has a profound
impact on the academic,
extracurricular, and
social lives of students and
serves as an important conduit between
the students, faculty and staff.
Serving on the SA is
a tremendous amount of work.
Most of which happens behind the scenes,
and
is the foundation for
much of the student experience.
So please join me again in
a round of applause for
this committed group of student leaders.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> At
this time I would like to ask
the Arbuckle Leadership Fellows to stand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The Leadership Fellows program plays
an integral role in the GSB Leadership
curriculum by bringing together a group of
talented second year students to support
the leadership development
of the first year class.
On behalf of the school,
I thank these 68 students for
their tireless work, their extraordinary
dedication to their MBA1 squads and
coaches, and for inspiring a significant
number of first year students
to seek out this unique
leadership opportunity.
They are a role model for
student leadership at its best.
Please join me in thanking this
remarkable group of students.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Finally,
I would like to ask the student leaders
of the global study trips, the social
innovation study trips, and the Stanford
Tsinghua exchange program to please stand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> These 102 outstanding student leaders
partnered with the school on a critical
component of the GSB education,
the global experience requirement.
They served as peer educators for
almost 600 students, traveling to
23 countries, helping them discover
how business skills are relevant in a wide
variety of industries and institutions.
As the GSB show made clear, they succeeded
in driving home an important lesson,
different countries are different.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> For
acting as ambassadors to the GSB and for
their indelible impact on
the students they led, we thank them.
Please join me in a round of applause for
this exceptional group of students.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In the next few
minutes we will begin reading the names of
the graduates in alphabetical order and
we'll invite them forward
to receive their diploma.
Names will be read by Derrick Bolton,
Assistant Dean for MBA Admissions and
Margaret Hayes, Assistant Dean for
the MBA program.
Graduates will receive their
diplomas from Dean Saloner.
So, as Garth mentioned, we have the great
privilege to have Dean Miller here today.
All of you have undoubtedly heard of Arjay
Miller, and from the great reception he
got, I presume many of you
are friends of Arjay Miller as well.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Arjay
served in the US Air Force
during the second World War and
was later one of the so-called whiz kids
who revolutionized Ford Motor Company.
Arjay became president of Ford and
then later the much admired full
Dean of the GSB from 1968 to 1978.
His sterling leadership of
the school is legendary.
In honor of Dean Miller's service, the top
10% of the class ranked by academic
performance are designated
as Arjay Miller Scholars.
As we read the names of the graduates,
we will also announce if they have
achieved the distinction
of Arjay Miller Scholar.
And the award comes with
a special privilege,
Dean Miller will personally congratulate
the Arjay Miller Scholars after
they have received their
diploma from Dean Saloner.
Margaret and Derrick,
would you please begin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Vincent Adnee.
>> Maria Nail Abramson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Adams.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tammer Adal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Monica Adilla.
>> Mahmoud Adee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dan Adler, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Nema Amati.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Arjun Atzu, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Aziz Afallel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brad Allen.
>> Mohammed Mazon Amommen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hatham al-Salama.
>> Abdul Aziz al-Salam.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Asmat al-Amani.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Mauricio Amores Ryder.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amen Easterling Anderson.
>> Kyle Anderson, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jonathan Azsmith, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Melanie Gerell Axelgaard.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Arga Avas.
>> Naomi Bagdones
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Moritz Bear, RJ Miller Scholar
>> AJ Balance
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emily Sikh Baldwin.
>> Aditi Vanga, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bartika Bansol.
>> Colin Jason Barsalu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jeff Barnes.
>> Brookes Barren
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Diego Bartel
>> Joy Bosum
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Victoria Brook Beasley
>> Constantine Bilayf
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Joseph Benjamin,
RJ Miller Scholar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jeff Bergquist.
>> David Burkle.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dan Bershinski.
>> Bigya Phat
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Excuse me.
Louisa Bett.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Vidja Batt.
>> Elizabeth Danielson Bird,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Roger Allen Brim.
>> Aya Briller.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Laura Brookheiser, R.J.
Miller scholar,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lorenzo Brooks Jr.
>> Ahmad Brown
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jeffrey Brownlo.
>> APPLAUSE]
>> Nicholas Bunn.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Clark Berkel.
>> Virginia Wadsworth Calkins
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Caelian
>> Matthew Ronald Cano
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Britt Caputo
>> David Rhomer Carlson
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rachel Rhomer Carlson
>> Mikaley Costrazano.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Karen Chan.
>> Sally Chang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tich Chagameeray
>> Angela Chapman
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Haleezay Chilomiya
>> Helen Chen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Teen Chen.
>> Felipe Chico.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Harrison Chilton.
>> Theresa Chin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Robert Clark.
>> All right G!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Martis Clayton.
>> Megan Klein.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Tyler Coats.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Miles Collins.
>> Adam Jay Spankey Compain.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Cooper.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Mario Coronado.
>> Christopher Patrick Cazon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jessica Craig.
Brittany Crooks.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Cunningham Crump.
>> Anthony Kerns.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Evan Dar.
>> Sarah Dojenie.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eliiott Demasheck,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cheryl Davenport.
>> Ian Michael Debode.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Luigi Decurtis.
>> Carlos Enrique.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Carlos Miguel Del Poso.
>> Rachel Delarentis.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Carrie Denning.
>> Belva Devara.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Nick Dewilda.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Craig Dewitt.
>> Horacio Diaz Ara.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Anchuman Divania.
>> Galena Jorgavich.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Pui Qu Dwan.
>> Deborah Donaldson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gorav Dossi.
>> Brittney Dribelbas.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mickey Due.
>> Joe Dubay.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sam Duboff, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Phillippa Duffy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nerissa Nicole Duswalt.
>> Ryan Ebanks.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Carl Eber, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Hayden Clark Edwards.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Asaf Anot.
>> Tim Eisenman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brian Herc Echo.
>> Gabriel Elizondo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Adam Drew Epstein.
>> Elizabeth Blair Epstein,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eric Thomas Epstein.
>> Laura Christine Allen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Chris Fott.
>> Kevin Ferguson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniela Fernandez, Carlos Aguerra.
>> Roman Fetusoff.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brian Fielder.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Nicholas Hudson Flanders.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Friter.
>> Eric Fong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lisa Forsell, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Nora Beth Friedman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andre Freighety.
>> Zachary Brandon Fuchs.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Johnson Fung.
>> Colin Paul Gowley.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Alee Gaura.
>> Cedric Garcia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Goodit Garg.
>> Alexander Gart.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gabriel Garza Rodriguez.
>> Fashoda Botabow Smith.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Anwar Gosh.
>> Kia Garashi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jerry Jackamin Collier.
>> Federico Jillson Pagilia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Gowalla.
>> Cameron Nordack Grace.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elizabeth Kriner Grace.
>> Sam Grausz, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Rachel McKay Green.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Keith Michael Gross,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Isabel Gischar Kutina.
>> Jerov Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rajah Gupta, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Richa Gupta.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> John Stanton Haddock.
>> Gretchen Hale.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brian Hammond.
>> Brian Matthew Harper.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sarah Maxwell Harrison.
>> Bennett Houser.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Erin Heydenstrite.
>> Christina Elaine Heggai.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Arthur Grant Heidrich,
IV, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sarah Herringer.
>> Tenyun Ho.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gregory Adam Hollander,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jonathan Hollander.
>> Michael Andrew Howard.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Michelle Hwong.
>> Char Hung Hu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brian Humphrey, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Sebastian Hutchinson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ezipi Arakawa.
>> Brit Jameson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Francois Javier Zham.
>> Michelle Emjay Jang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amanda Rene Johnson.
>> Charles Houston Johnson, Jr.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kipp Johnson.
>> Archie Dawt Joshie.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rodrigo Juarez.
>> Unjee Jennifer Jun.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Namiko Kajiwara.
>> Sam Camara.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Molly Kang.
>> Fabio Maraz Khan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nimoy Joe Panapoli
>> Sasha Kazas
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sherif Casantay
>> Claudia Anna Castellanutz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amita Cowdrey Katrigatta.
>> Kevin Thomas Kelleher.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caroline Kenny Kim.
>> Brandon Kernes.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shawn Desmond Ketrick.
>> Jillian Kilby.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Suquon Keem.
>> Keeral Cloakoff.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Adam Klotz.
>> John Komkoff, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yanes Caracas.
>> Yeah, Yanee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Crowdhammer.
>> Zachary Brannon Kruth.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Aurora Kurland.
>> Peter Layfer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Walden Hoye Ming Lam.
>> Claire Kayden Lambert.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maria Longott.
>> Sydney Alexandra Rigby Larson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Paul Wassar.
>> Daniel Lahey.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Grant Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sabrina Villa Lahey.
>> Tyler Douglas Leoni.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Philippe Leroy.
>> Carolina Lescano.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ronald Lewis.
[APPLAUSE].
Alex Hunsing Lee.
Kristen Chen Lee.
[APPLAUSE].
Linus Leang.
Heejay Lin.
Arjay Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Ross Allen Lipstein.
RJ Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Cathy Leu.
Davis Liu.
[APPLAUSE].
Alexander Adonis Laughton.
Ryan Laughlin.
[APPLAUSE].
Alec Lovett.
Elizabeth Shaw Lowe.
[APPLAUSE].
Gwynn Luca.
Patricia Ludwig, R.J.
Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Jungian Loa.
Joshua Lights.
[APPLAUSE].
Hasan McLuif.
Justin Maletsky.
[APPLAUSE].
Manolis Manasockies.
Gary Mao.
[APPLAUSE].
Jorge Edwardo Marcos Bores.
Alexander Marlantus.
[APPLAUSE].
Alexis Sapeda Mall.
Phil Mazera.
[APPLAUSE].
Emily Macateer, RJ Miller Scholar.
Michael Riley McLure.
[APPLAUSE].
James Fitzpatrick McKenna.
Alley McNaughton Adams.
[APPLAUSE].
Jordan Menam.
Munsey Morita.
[APPLAUSE].
Alex Melamug.
Lucas Meindas.
[APPLAUSE].
Irram Martel.
Dave Meyer.
[APPLAUSE].
Karen Michelson.
Kirk Michael Frederick Miles.
[APPLAUSE].
Ama Misa.
Wesley Ann Martizi.
[APPLAUSE].
Garret Donald Morgan.
Ben Morley, RJ Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Michael Morley.
Cedric Morris.
[APPLAUSE].
Ormuz Mastophe.
Kevin Mullins.
[APPLAUSE].
Jared T Murphy.
Steven Edd ie Murphy.
[APPLAUSE].
Mateo Musso.
Sue Ann Nayar.
[APPLAUSE].
Hamish Namen.
Matthew Neil.
[APPLAUSE].
Grant Nelson.
Mark Honeywell Newman.
[APPLAUSE].
Anita Nguyengara.
Anna Ninen.
[APPLAUSE].
Isabella Nunez Monizio.
Peter Nurenburg, RJ Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Tomas Ocompo.
Marcella Ocello Ramos.
[APPLAUSE].
Christian Ogaway, Jr..
Javier Ortega, RJ Miller Scholar.
[APPLAUSE].
Julia Park.
Sarah Elizabeth Penny.
[APPLAUSE].
Marcello Peekey.
Natalie Wallace Pico.
[APPLAUSE].
Tom Pico [APPLAUSE].
Whitney Ping.
[APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE]
>> Susan Michelle Pomeier.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jay Poppet.
>> Alane Marie Preston,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Ashley Renee Prince
>> [APPLAUSE],
>> Claire Quinn
>> Almar Riaz Karyshe, RJ Miller Scholar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Byron Radford
>> Adrian Romey.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alberto Ramos Elizondo.
>> Nan Ransohoff.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dan Rasmussen.
>> Brain Wrecked.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alberto Rakenya Iffar.
>> Erick Reuland.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Scott Risvani.
>> Sarah Imrisk.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mike Robertson.
>> Andrew Roget.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jennifer Nicole Rosenfeld.
>> Colin John Rutledge
>> [APPLAUSE],
>> Federico DeHenuso
>> Mikhail Russ
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jun Yun Reung.
>> Didya Chandra Cypresad.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Le Jun Sajio.
>> Valerie Sacymora.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christine Aubrey Sanders.
>> Neil Sengal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sader Sonby, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Matt Saucito.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Evan Andrew Schlossberg.
>> Sophie Schmidt.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicholas Schmidts.
>> Barrant Peter Schriver.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elaina Strichovichi Palozo
>> [APPLAUSE],
>> Santiago Sculley
>> Peter Andrew Seibert
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lauren Shy Sideman.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Julia Ray Seltzer.
>> Kyle Shackleton.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dawson Shamblan.
>> Hey, Dawson!
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thrifby Shankar.
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Sharoon.
>> Erick Shagar, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elizabeth Shribman.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Shteranberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Silva
>> [APPLAUSE],
>> Monica Semo
>> Whitney Skinner
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Slate.
>> Daniel Evan Wise Sobal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Brian Michael Solar.
>> Allison Summer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jenny Song.
>> Aaron Sousa.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Scott St. Marie.
>> Antony AKA Tony Stalin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Colin Cornelius Stalmecker.
>> Jordan Ray Stankowski.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Megan Star.
>> Abigail Stern.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Robert Stevenson.
>> Daniel Scott Stratford.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Schtumpf.
>> Jessie Sullivan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rebecca Taber.
>> Daniel Waping Tan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gwen Tanner.
>> Erin Thayer.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jennifer Wilcox-Thomas.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Allister Thornton.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hailey Tobin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jim Tormy.
>> Joyce Toyota.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nick Hiltricka.
>> Kathryn Lin Von.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lisa Renee Vermillion.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jessica Lee Veran Lindgard.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zoe Rogers Victor.
>> Stacy Velender.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Greg Vivarito.
>> Michael Boss.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Scott Caylor Wagner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alec Kennedy Walker.
>> Dorothy Walter.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Fiona Walter.
>> Christine Wang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Danlee Wong.
>> Jeffery Wang
>> Margaret Meylang Wang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yi Pei Wong.
>> Kelly Alverson Wannup.
Arjay Scholar.
>> Angel Wei.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Wendy Wen.
>> Nathan Werland.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Chris Westrom.
Jessica Elaine Wheeler.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mihael Vishkovsky.
>> Rachel Wetlac.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Charles Michael Wolfson.
>> Ochena Baker Walworth.
Arla Jajao.
Joy Shi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Chung Seng.
Elise Shu.
Osman Bercer Yoncha.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Pujon Wao.
>> Jon Su Philip Yen,
Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mabe Yusef.
>> Rebecca Yew, R.J. Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Joanne Yuann.
>> Joyce Jong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Kaiphung Zang.
Zo Zhou.
Samuel Zhong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shan Zhan.
>> Lauren Rachel Zletz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ivanna Zsupa, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Congratulations to the MBA, MSX and
PhD classes of 2015.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It now is my pleasure to
introduce the presentation of awards.
Susan Arbuckle will present
the Arbuckle award,
followed by Madavrajan who will present
the RubercheckAward and the Ford Scholar.
Susan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'm
proud to be here in my fathers name
presenting an award that carries
forward the values of character and
activism that he lived.
Stanford and the people of the business
school were dear to his heart and
integral to his life for decades.
>From his early days as
an undergraduate in the 1930s,
as an MBA student, and to the Dean in
the 1960s, and later as a trustee.
Nominated and chosen by his or
her peers, the recipient of the Ernest C
Arbuckle Award is the second year student,
who by his or her active participation,
initiative, leadership, and
personal integrity,
is judged as having contributed most
to the fulfillment of the goals of
the Graduate School of Business in his or
her actions,
both within school and society.
Classmates described this year's recipient
with the following comments, and
if you suspect who it is before
I finish reading the accolades,
please let me continue so everyone can
hear why this student was nominated.
This student, and I quote,
has been a pillar, perhaps the pillar,
of the GSP community
over the past two years.
The glue that brings both classes of
the GSB together through academic,
social, and
community service related endeavors.
This person is a natural leader,
a positive personality
who befriended everyone.
With an enthusiasm and spirit that
embodies the highest values of GSB,
this student has worked to improve
the inclusiveness of our class.
Another student said, unlike most of us,
who get caught up in focusing on how
we can best achieve our own goals,
this person's sole focus was on
improving the lives of others.
There is so much more that this
person does behind the scenes,
that makes the GSP a wonderful place.
The impact if felt by all.
An upstanding and respectful citizen,
in all interactions.
This individual organized fellow
students to use their skills to
help local small business'.
This student has shown
an unparalleled enthusiasm to gather
perspectives from all classmates
in order to put ideas into action.
And better serve the broader community as
Co-President of the student association.
He showed his relentless desire
to help both classmates and
others by championing and creating the
Community Engagement Committee as well as
the GSB Beyond the Bubble initiative.
With much appreciation,
I present this award to Brian Solar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The Alexander A Robicheaux Student
Achievement Award in Finance
was established to honor
Professor Robicheaux's outstanding
contribution to the teaching of finance at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
from 1960 until his death in 1978.
The award is given to an MBA student
selected by the Finance Faculty for
outstanding achievement
in the finance courses.
The recipient receives the award and
also has his or
her name engraved on a plaque at the GSP.
This year's recipient of the Robicheaux
award is Peter Nurnberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Among the RJ MIllers Scholars,
one student's academic achievement places
him or her at the top of the class.
This student is designated as
the Henry Ford II, Scholar.
The recipient's name is engraved on
a plaque on permanent display at the GSB.
The student also receives
a substantial cash award.
How substantial?
We chose the biggest
number we could think of.
One year's tuition at the GSB.
I’m delighted that this year’s recipient
is someone who not only excelled in
studies, but
also the contributed significantly to
the broader intellectual environment at
GSB as a member of the academic committee.
The 2015 Henry Ford Scholar
is Sagar Sanghvi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> That concludes the 2015 Stanford GSB
graduation ceremony.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you all for
coming and making this a special day.
I invite all of you to join us now for
receptions for each group of graduates of
the night management center
as noted in your program.
Let's have all of the graduates stand as
we give a final round of applause for
the class of 2015.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]